I deserve some of the blame. I made my farm
scape too inviting.
Okay, this is a mess.
What are we going to do now?
I got your blanket, Mr. Goat.
No no no no no no no. We're going to wait for
Santa Claus by the chimney.
But it's Thanksgiving.
What about Mr. Goat? How come I don't hear him anymore?
Ah, Mr. Goat is fine.
Bahhh!!
Did you hear that?
What is it, Mr. Goat?
Bahh!
He's saying that he needs some time
alone. Look, there's some cookies for Santa here.
Why don't you go and sit by the chimney
and wait?
Santa!
Okay, look, it's not my place to try to
parent your kids.
Good.
But one thing we learned on the farm is that death is a part
of life.
If you tell Joe what happened to that goat, death is
going to be part of your life.
Okay, you know what?
Kids can handle a lot more than you think.
And every step from birth till the end has
its own magical beauty.
So, do we jam the goat in the garbage or heave
it over the fence?
Teach your children well.